I'd like to talk about some advanced cache updates. Say
we have this problem where multiple people submit posts to Ascii
Chan at the same time, or submit to your blog at
the exact same time. You know, let's say they hit multiple
app servers, or different app servers. They both write to
the database at the same time, and then they both update
the cache at the same time. Overwriting each other. This can
happen. This is a type of race condition where you know,
two updates come in at the same time, and we don't know
what order to handle them in and they both squawk them, basically one
tramples the other. If we to draw this in a picture, it
looks something like this. Say we've got two apps servers. Here's an example
of the problem. And we've got our database. And we've got our
cache. And say we've got el, elements in our database. We're going to call
them one and two. And these app servers are both going to get
requests from the user to, to submit a new entry into our database,
you know, our new piece of art for ASCIIchan. And this
happens at the same time. So this guy may submit element three.
And this guy may submit element four. So our database is, you
know, in sync because databases enforce these constraints. You know, you can
insert as many things as you want at the same time the
database will order it all for you. But here's the problem. Let's
start with version one of this problem which is. Each of these
app servers is manipulated in the cache directly. So this guy inserts
element 3, and so he writes to the cache
and he says, the database looks like this. And just
as he does this, this app server finishes inserting item
4 into the database and he is not communicating with
this app. He overwrites the cache to instead look like
this. 1,2,4. Because this app server, remember we're not doing
another query form the database, we're just manipulating the cache
direectly. This app server squashed the other app server's update.
That's, that's a problem. Now, let's look at another way this
problem can ahppen. Say we were using the the first approach
we talked about where we, when we write to the database
we immediately do a read from the database and update our
cache that way. We can still have this problem. First, this
App server inserts element 3 into the data base. And then
it says okay you know, let's, let's rerun the query, so
we, so we can update the cache. But at the same time,
this other App server Inserts element four into the database, and
it also wants to rerun the query. So, each of these,
you know, has a view of the database. This first app
server thinks it's 1, 2, 3, and this other guy thinks
it's 1, 2, 3, 4. Now, there's no guarantee this first
app server will write to the cache for this one. because,
things can happen out of order. Your app server can have
a slight delay, you know, there can be a network glitch.
There's going to be any number of reasons why this app server might run.
You know might have a little hiccup and this guy writes you know,
or, or, or this guys gets the right to the cache first. 1,2,3,4.
And this other guy comes in and tramples on top of him. So
there are a handful of ways where these app servers can you know,
overwrite each other and if we, if, if we are redirecting the user
to our front page to do the cache update that way. The, the
odds of this happening is even more
likely because it's not going to happen quite
so fast, we've gotta go all the way to the user
and back before we update our cache. So, that's the problem, you
know, multiple app servers overriding each other in the cache because the
cache doesn't have any transactions, it doesn't have any of the fancy
stuff that the data base has. You know on that base we
juts say insert this element but on the cache we say the
list of elements is this so we can't just answer it at
the front of it let me introduce one solution to this problem.